we turn now to our series protecting the
planet which explores environmental
challenges and Solutions in a changing
climate this morning we're looking at
the deadly consequences of large ships
colliding with whales Federal officials
are investigating an alarming spike in
well deaths 18 have washed up on the
East Coast beaches since December 1st
experts believe whales have been drawn
closer to shore this winter by their
food sources into Waters crowded with
large ships Ben Tracy shows us how
scientists are deploying new technology
on both coasts to try to keep some of
the largest creatures on the planet
alive
off the coast of Santa Barbara
California the Rising Sun paints its
first watercolor of the day and the race
is on to get this out to sea before the
sea gets too rough
kind of rocking and rolling out here now
is this make it harder for you guys yeah
for sure it's a little bumpy today but
we can't always have nice days out here
it's not a sightseeing trip it's a
mission to save lives and this could be
a high-tech Lifesaver so that's the big
thing behind you there that is the big
buoy behind me engineer Jeff Pietro with
the Woods Hole oceanographic institution
helped build this buoy at the heart of a
new system called whale safe
he carefully Maneuvers it off the back
of the boat
and into the rolling waves it's Tethered
to an underwater microphone that detects
whale songs
the Santa Barbara channel is a prime
feeding ground for these massive and
often endangered sea creatures it's also
a major thoroughfare for the only thing
bigger than they are shipping vessels
and cruise ships given the size of a
whale you don't think of something else
being much of a threat to it but these
vessels are so much bigger than the
whales are yeah you know for example the
blue whale the largest animal to ever
live up to 100 feet no match for a
thousand foot cargo ship Cali Lee part
is a scientist with whale safe which is
funded by billionaire Salesforce
co-founder mark benioff it uses data
from its buoys satellites and entries on
a whale watching app to predict the
presence of whales in shipping lanes
warning the companies in near real time
so they can voluntarily slow down to 10
knots a speed set by a federal age
agency shown to significantly reduce the
risk of fatal collisions there was a
study done a few years ago that s
estimated that 80 endangered Blue Fin
and humpback whales are killed on the
U.S West Coast every year buy ships buy
ships recent years have seen record West
Coast whale deaths with a notable
exception of 2020 when the pandemic all
but stopped international shipping
scientists say most ship strike deaths
go undetected because the whales sink to
the bottom of the ocean
there was outrage last year when a
beloved 49-foot whale washed up on shore
South of San Francisco
spotted hundreds of times during her
life scientists even gave her a name
Fran she was found with extensive
bruising and a broken neck injuries
consistent with a ship strike having
such a well-known loved will die from
something that we know is preventable is
it's tragic
wheel safe is now naming and shaming
shipping companies and cruise ships that
don't slow down assigning them letter
grades Celebrity Cruise lines was given
a d a cooperation rate of about 38
percent two of the largest West Coast
shippers get F's slowing down less than
18 percent of the time we asked all of
these companies for comment only Matson
responded saying in a statement it is
quote working to meet the recommended
speeds no vessel no Waterway user would
ever want to strike a well it is a
tragic tragic accident Jacqueline Moore
is with a trade group that represents
the West Coast shipping industry she
argues most vessel carriers do slow down
but the shipping industry relies on them
to deliver Goods on time if you have the
information that a whale is in the area
what would be the reason a ship would
not slow down there's really three main
issues efficiency safety and schedule
and schedule is really Paramount here
any delays based on slowing a vessel
down can greatly impact the schedules
on the East Coast speed limits are
mandatory to protect the endangered
North Atlantic right whale data show
ships there comply 80 percent of the
time on the west coast where slowing
down is voluntary compliance is just 60
percent whale safe is hoping to change
that and the whole idea here I imagine
is to figure out how to coexist exactly
to give one of the great creatures of
the sea a chance to survive
for CBS mornings Ben Tracy off the coast
of Santa Barbara
yeah it's really hard to monitor I mean
and then you talk about it being
voluntary on certain coasts yeah yeah
and it would be a very sad thing if
those whales were not around anymore
right about that